è la più di ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo
sotto arti paito blogging privo di cui
già ragazzi volevo premessa un attimino
perché io avevo fatto già un video su
tanti pezzo blogging circa due anni e
mezzo fa se non erro quindi tipo quando
c'erano i dinosauri in poche parole
schivo ragazzi ci tengo a condividere
questo capolavoro con tutti voi
ho deciso di giocarci ragazzi anche
anche perché ogni con un cazzo quindi va
bene così
allora io vi faccio questa premessa non
mi ricordo bene come come come però
sappiate che fate per assistere ad una
delle cose più cosa cazzo sto guardando
di tutta la vostra vita vado ragazzi
abbiamo più anche qualcuno cc stupri
buongiorno e rega lasciatemelo dire
siete veramente figli ve lo dico
soprattutto tu tu tu sei figo peccato ci
sono delle bottiglie madonna che è una
roba tipo non può ubriaco pare che
adesso perdere sti qui chiamano la
polizia qualcosa del genere c'è un
quadro storto e questo me lo ricordo c'è
eccolo lì perché madonna peggio di harry
potter ragazzi mar ma la cosa strana è
visto già perché dopo tutti questi anni
non ho ancora capito perché solo perché
non c'è ciao ciao tu sei anita ragazzi
vi presento anita magra gnocca io io amo
le donne col fucile ragazzi le amo e
belize che cos'è sta roba
con proiettili alicia keys ottobre i
proietti che mi infilo poi nel
nell'astuccio certo ragazzi non so chi
sia tu sto parlando alla radio ma una
voce bellissima intanto continua bene
ciò che non ri no no lui lui lui e chuck
norris a prescindere dalla presa bella
che c'è ci sono di mitra che mi i file
raw comodamente nelle mutande perché non
sono gli sta mettendo non importa che
andiamo avanti anche le papere
entra come fatto perché nostro non
chiedetevi perché ma non importa andiamo
avanti regala penso che abbiate capito
che comunque prima di fare sto gioco i
creatori si siano fumati leggermente un
po di bamba che fa che fa cup referendum
non voglio lasciarmi sono ragazze che
stavano miei amici miei amici voglio
che cazzo ragazzi cece anni dall ala la
mia adorata anni da che mi sta puntando
con un fucile e la cosa non me la
ricordavo tra l'altro bellissimo allora
gli hobby piccola cosa
non conosco molto sulle donne ma so che
se una donna già un fucile e le
mestruazioni meglio e levarsi dai
[ __ ] quindi ragazzine orly a tecnici
anche c'è mai stato colpito da di salvo
di salvo è perfetto io sarebbero ciak
perché perché lui lui merita di vivere
una persona degna mafiosa righe che
peccato kit ha sparato zio è stata nihil
confidati com'è stata netta
il logo è stata laico la stronza di
merda a me neanche piaceva
aiuto aiuto un ferito ragazzi o morto o
morti in mano qualcuno mi aiuti cazzo di
niente dalla la gente strozza per me c'è
un tizio che sta guardando gli aiuto
aiuto aiuto che cazzo ti ascolti la
musica sta morendo
se sei veramente bello lo so ascolto zio
sto parlando con te con te casco con
teca scotti britney spears mentre io son
morti in mano io l'ho io tifo ecco suo
gusto carrello vero morgan che se non ti
fosse troppo direi tanti di quegli
schiaffi che non è dei ragazzi è una
mano vi prego una mano c'è un morto c'è
un caso non è morto ma quasi
stavo dormendo non lo ricordavo questo
chi chiede anita anita sanità che cazzo
fai se tirandolo in parchetti le bucce
d'arancia al balcone o telefona è grazie
mira quanto mi piace l'arancia fatta a
cubetti bellissima e la cia che ci fai
qua anche per me è un piacere vederti
amico dove andate
mi sono venuti a trovare ma non so
perché anita doveva già che mi sto
rubando la moglie brutto bastardo vieni
qui anita anita mia all'inter mia devi
toglierti dai [ __ ] devi tagliate ma
dove cazzo andate con le bottiglie
ok ma vorrei che a quella scappato con
mia moglie senza senso tra l'altro era
casa che casta testimoni di famiglia il
piace e allora sei stronzo
grazie parte che non ho ancora capito
perché io sto sovraffollamento di gatti
ehi ciao bella [ __ ] come stai quello che
mi è rimasto il fascino come pochi
ragazzi sono troppo ispirato devo
dedicare una poesia tipo la lamiera e
blu il tuo ciuffo e rosso t scopo più
non posso
sì certo ma forse non lo rimorchiato
come si deve ma non importa avremo tempo
ve lo garantisco che cosa fanno questi
metti su skrillex sempre comunque meglio
di me rega ma che bello che ci sono gli
sposini quanto mi state simpatici non
avete idea eccovi qua brutti stronzi e
non mi avete invitato maledetti basati
che fanno sì sì esistono scottare porca
[ __ ] sto ascoltando anche state per
assistere al più bel discorso mai fatto
nella storia pronti via nuovo moto fuoco
dopo il discorso più commovente di tutta
la mia vita
ragazzi sto andando a merda sto andando
a merda furia di bei ragazzi che sotto
la doccia
non so perché non so quando mi chiama
pasta quanto sto bevendo rega questo in
coma etilico
ok abbiamo bevuto io e anita ragazzi
sono sbaglia eccola lì per vedere un fa
vj sexy donna vuoi vederlo che cazzo non
ho capito o dio
jackie poche altre siamo di nuovo qui
sono caduto da un bel po di mettere i
ragazzi mi pare di ricordare che da qui
in poi non ci capisco più un cazzo non
che prima ci capisce qualcosa è però
perché siamo di nuovo dov'era un prima
siamo praticamente che adesso non c'è un
cristo nel dell'aeroporto prima era
pieno di gente dai tantos che ci sia
gente non sono utili uguali perché prima
non sapevano una secca già che calzi il
fatto che a 16 al casto ragazzi questo è
a ha rubato le caramelle io io lo so che
l'ho visto è una cosa no no kat
vai vai così bravo bravo jahan dodo
spingerti a bra mamma mia che però che
fenomeni devono prenderci come cast del
film di 007 io ho sempre detto sta corda
perché azione domenichino mi dicono
queste cose però non problemi stanno
messa al culo sa chi cazzo sparacia 3
cao dio ci sono dei ci sono delle delle
cose con il bar accaduto col paracadute
che vogliono ucciderci bello cosa che
cazzo sono sì cosima
[ __ ] ok ho mancato o mancato
qualsiasi cosa volessi prendere ma non
importa cioè tipo ce l'abbiamo fatta
regalo non so perché arci l'uscita di
suscitati siamo ci siamo veloci bello se
tutto non tanto c'è siamo nel mondo
della pantera rosa cosa fa anche rima
merda e sono queste le giornate in cui
capisci che una giornata di merda perché
effettivamente siamo e come cazzo
abbiamo fatto a scappare spiegatemelo e
chi cazzo sta guidando adesso mentre
guardo indietro ha spiegato e mi sa che
ma che mirror immer noch ai ciak non sei
prendere un cazzo abbiate pazienza
stiamo stiamo andando a fruttare con la
moto al motorino senza motivo io non te
l'ho mai detto anita mai degli occhi
bellissimi cazzo guarda strada
ok questo è questo e pelato
credo di aver rifinito uno dei giochi
più belli che abbia mai visto io ve lo
dico perché non ho parole veramente
giuro sti giochi mimì mi danno emozioni
ed ecco la porta della giustizia che
ancora e ancora basta
no adesso guardi la strada però è
comunque gaio spero vi sia piaciuto
anche se breve perché comunque come
gioco è meraviglioso perché perché lo è
e basta
i ragazzi dire che possono concludere
qui cosa sente le casse il video è
piaciuto questo argomento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e con ogni
videocrate nella descrizione chelsea
discrete vinci vi dico subito che la
ragazza